[Music]
for el salvador's president naibu kelly
the ceremony to mark three years in
office was a triumphant event he had
something to announce
we're at the point of winning the war
against the gangs nobody thought it was
possible that's not just trump for
police and security forces but the whole
population
[Music]
he's referring to a two month long and
ongoing crackdown on the ms-13 and
barrio 18 gangs mass arrests and
security checkpoints in the communities
they control
most of the population wholeheartedly
support that this is a land where gangs
have killed raped and extorted for
decades
every day there are less people paying
the gang's extortion many have lost
their fear of going out or that
something will happen to a loved one for
the first time people are feeling the
peace
but there's another side to this at
least 34 000 people have been arrested
under a state of emergency which has
seen some civil rights suspended and
inevitably some innocent people sucked
into the prison system along with the
guilty
mother's way on mass outside of the
country's jails for news of their sons
the police admit they've been given
arrest quotas to me
amnesty international announced in their
report this thursday that due process
has been swept away
amnesty international has found that
thousands of people are being detained
without an arrest warrant instead the
police are making mass arrests based on
unverified anonymous accusations or if
people have a prison record tattoos or
have a relative in a gang if they've
denounced police abuses or just because
they live in a gang-controlled community
meanwhile even as the president grapples
with the gangs another crisis looms
buchelli has gambled heavily on bitcoin
making the cryptocurrency legal tender
in the country
but that great experiment had just one
mention in his speech two minutes from
the end a sign of how a celebrated
policy has become a millstone
so far he's lost the country tens of
millions in buying up bitcoin before the
price crashed
a one billion dollar bitcoin back bond
that he announced with much fanfare last
year has also been put on ice
it was all meant to help el salvador pay
its mounting foreign debts now
economists worry the country will
default so even as president buchelli's
supporters chanted for his re-election
on wednesday night
a moment of reckoning could be getting
closer
john holman al jazeera